ambiance vip pour le premier jour du
salon de la gastronomie des outre mer à
paris sous l'impulsion de la
chroniqueuse et auteur gastronomique
babette de rozières des exposants de
tous ces territoires ont fait le
déplacement
et parmi eux 8 stand de la réunion pour
exporter le meilleur laissant la réunion
ne l'a mené deux semaines avant lorsque
sam en haïti après pau être présent dans
l'outre-mer gastronomie les produits va
avec le thème du salon l'outre-mer et
c'est la réunion également
et si on fait pas attention on n'a pas
la plupart du temps tu peux oublier en
or il faut être présent aux objectifs va
déjà si de faire découvrir
gens de la métropole nos produits mais
aussi de faire venir va les réunionnais
qui sont
a paris sur la métropole pour
redécouvrir les produits eva qui
reviennent vers leurs racines bas
notamment à la crème de patate douce à
la vanille donc ça attire bien le client
et ensuite on a la fameuse bande miel
qui a été médaillé et on a plein de
confiture à vous proposer des piments et
notamment là on va être sur le sens de
l'agriculture pour représenter des de
confiture au concours c'est vrai que ça
me coûte très cher mais ça permet de
faire connaître mon produit est aussi
comme il ya beaucoup de parisiens qui
viennent en vacances à la réunion à
moyen terme
ben je récupère moyen terme mais c'est
vrai qu'il faut au moins le dos solide
parce que il ya énormément de fouet et
on y trouve également certains de mes
produits à la boutique du département et
ça permet aussi quand je fais des salons
des embryons ont été mes clients c'est
cette boutique parce qu'il faut dire
comme comme c'est le le métro il ne sait
pas si il ya une boutique de la réunion
donc voilà je suis encore un maillon de
la petite chaîne
d'autres exposants ont choisi de sauter
la mer depuis bien longtemps et eux
aussi ont besoin de visibilité ya un
petit projecteur sur notre destination
et sur ce qu'on sait faire c'est-à-dire
à manger et on sait bien faire à manger
bien que huit stands de la rényon fait
mais c'est pas mal par rapport à l'année
dernière au yen avec un besoin de
s'occuper de sa diaspora lob de
l'outre-mer et parce que alors s'occuper
non mais la mettre en avant essayer de
se rassembler c'est bien parce que
souvent on est chacun dans son petit
coin est un petit peu isolé et en étant
ensemble on est un peu plus visible on
va dire alors voilà quelques wii grand
jack en ruine
ben nous para o comment on appelle au
magasin s'agencent d'avoir communiqué
aux messieurs
et puis nous ramène chez nous il veut qu
on mange toujours rigoler chez moi
jamais français toujas réunionnais au
courant comme en vaut quoi
zappos voir un peu le mot pays pouvoir
un peu mon île au pilon
partout oui il
alors cette histoire à une date de 2008
à partir de bras panon asia food j'ai
demandé à ma direction de développer
l'export mais de manière
plus précise en étant sur place et
je me suis porté volontaire pour faire
le voyage réunion-métropole voilà en
exportant ces petites douceurs de la
réunion le bouchon et voir si ça si ça
prenait
c'est le goût de la réunion dans la
bouche simplement
quel que soit le chemin le marché
national et international peut être
accessible par une nouvelle porte
d'entrée
la boutique île de la réunion les agents
du conseil départemental ont ici un
autre rôle
une action d'avenir le rapport qu'on a
aux exposants est particulier parce que
nous ce qu'on propose c'est on propose
un véritable partenariat avec e on
propose de relayer leurs produits on
rentre pas du tout en concurrence avec
eux au contraire notre but c'est de les
aider de remplir leurs carnets de
commande et de les aider à s'implanter
sur le territoire national et pourquoi
pas aller à l'international puisque le
lieu s'y prête
laissons là toute l'année l'avantagé
qu'on a à la rue du renard en plein
coeur de paris à trente secondes de
l'hôtel de ville
c'est que on a une clientèle
internationale qui hélas non seulement
pendant les périodes estivales ou de
vacances mais aussi tout au long de
l'année
la diaspora réunionnaise en redemande
vaincre les difficultés d'approché
fédérer cette volonté d'export du savoir
faire local passera peut-être par la rue
du renard
il n'ya plus qu'à pousser la porte